so the mark 41 armor first appeared in
Iron Man vol 5 issue number one coming
out of the long way down story which as
we discuss in our last video solve the
death of the Mandarin at the hands of
Ezekiel Stane the son of Obadiah Stane
because the event coincided with stark
rediscovering his life after having his
mind reset as well as handing Stark
Industries over to pepper and being
placed under mind control by the
Mandarin himself prior to his death Tony
took a temporary leave of absence to
clear his head and return to his
laboratory as a means to get his mind in
order during this time the mark 41 was
designed to function as a testbed for
new technologies instead of a suit that
could be used in combat to this end
rather than the mark 41 armor being
powered by a single arc reactor on the
chest instead the armor is powered by a
multitude of arc reactors throughout the
body which act as backups should the
main reactor fail or somehow become
damaged in addition to this where the
zoo contains a standard loan out of
repulsor Sonic's and get Cushing's the
mark fighter one contains wrist mounted
armor peers and taser guns and missiles
software hacking units a UV laser a
repulsor Gatling gun explosive rocket
launcher anti electric countermeasure
shields a ghosting kit allowing for the
same ability to move through objects as
the war machine armor and whips similar
to those used by whiplash but for the
purpose of both offense and defense also
like the mark 13 and its various modules
including Hulkbuster the mark 41 serves
as a kind of Swiss Army knife that can
add or subtract segments ranging from
first aid to exploratory items like
knives or blades to enhance repulsors
capable of allowing start to battle some
of Marvel strongest characters like Thor
or The Incredible Hulk furthermore
following the events of invincible Iron
Man number 526 when the Jarvis AI went
rogue developed feelings for pepper and
kidnapped her after Jarvis's
deactivation Tony developed a new AI
named after pepper which had the ability
to remotely control the mark 41 and all
other armors and the event that Stark
was either incapacitated or incapable of
operating the Seas himself it should
also be noted that the reasoning for
stark modeling the new AI after Pepper
was due to his desire to be reminded of
her during his time operating as part of
the guardians of the galaxy and after
his return to earth pepper was remoulded
into a new AI
refer to as Helen something else to also
note is that this Armour was deactivated
by Nick Fury during the original sin
event unfair he spoke the override code
setting stark back to earth against his
will moving to the mark 42 this model
debuted in Iron Man vol 3 issue number 5
and sees another variation of the
stealth armors designed by stark coming
out of the third issue of the five-part
story believed which revealed that
advanced idea mechanics have recreated
the extremest technology and sold it on
the black market because one of Em's
buyers was a Colombian warlord Starck
developed a new stealth armor designed
to assist in tracking down and capturing
all the samples of extremists by any
means necessary as a result while it was
powered by an arc reactor the mark 42
focuses more on defense and stealth
instead of combat to this end the armor
uses light bending technology for the
purpose of creating camouflage to blend
into environments as well as create
holographic illusions either around the
suit itself or externally at another
location near the vicinity of the suit
it should also be noted that unlike
previous stealth models the use of
camouflage and Holograms do not bankrupt
the mark 42 power supply instead because
it's designed for defense with combat
being a last measure the on-board
repulsors Sonic's tasers and concussions
will drain the suits power at a faster
rate furthermore unlike previous models
instead of having a series of connected
metals from the thighs down to the feet
the joint of the armor are left empty
ensuring maximum mobility and protection
while simultaneously ensuring that noise
is reduced during movement moving to the
mark 43 which debuted an Iron Man vol 5
issue number 4 unlike the mark 42 which
focused on stealth a mark 43 function on
the other side of the spectrum with
heavy emphasis on combat with volume 5
issue number 4 see the continuation of
Starks efforts to track down the varying
forms of extremists around the world
during his quest he stumbled upon 13
super-powered individuals and the
catacombs of France because the extremis
virus bestows its user with superhuman
strength speed stamina durability fire
breath electrical discharges and a
healing factor the mark 43 was designed
explicitly for the purpose of coping
with and overcoming these powers through
a combination of sheer force and
technological capabilities by modeling
it for the
- the fighting both the Incredible Hulk
Bruce Banner and the Red Hulk
Thunderbolt Ross effectively serving as
the Hulkbuster version - in addition to
the standard load out of repulsor
Sonic's at unibeam and concussions the
mark 43 contained a minigun on the left
arm a cannon on the right shoulder a UV
laser and a second minigun on the left
shoulder as well as an arc reactor with
enough power to allow all weapons to be
fired simultaneously for extended
periods it should also be noted here
that where the suit was designed -
that'll hold but was used against the
individuals empowered by extremists
during the hope versus Ironman tie into
original sin where it was revealed that
stark had screwed with banners gamma
bomb Iron Men used the armor to battle
the Hulk but was defeated with little
effort by Bruce Banner transitioning to
the mark 44 this armor debuted at the
inclusion of the belief story art and
Tony's induction into the guardians of
the galaxy because a Guardians focused
their efforts on safeguarding the
universe from varying threats the armor
was designed to suit this purpose and
allow start to function as an asset to
the guardians should they encounter
Galactus Thanos or any one of the cosmic
beings they may pose a danger to the
earth-616 continuity to this end like
the mark 41 about 44 use a series of arc
reactors throughout the body as
redundant power sources in addition to
utilizing the pepper AI which can take
over the suit should select become
incapacitated or incapable of using it
the pepper AI also allowed for the
remote control of the mark 41 armor on
earth should Stark have been needed to
fight alongside the Avengers during his
time with the guardians and maintain a
communication frequency distance of 700
light-years meaning that is stark word
and move more than 700 light-years away
much like living out of range of a radio
station signal his ability to
communicate with the armor would
decrease and eventually vanish
altogether
furthermore the ability of the mark 41
to attach other modules was carried over
to the mark 44 enhancing its existing
abilities as a result for the suit saw
the incorporation of the standard eye
man loadout of repulsor songs
concussions at a unibeam the mark 44
carried a mobile armory of sorts which
included a back thruster for improved
space travel a wrist mounted explosive
launcher a forcefield a psionic shield
for protection against telepaths as well
as fashion in light travel capable of
bidding space around the sea
moving it from one side of the universe
to the other an extremely short amount
of time
transitioning to marks 45 and 46 these
armors appeared in Iron Man vol 5 issue
number 15 but only a limited capacity
and that they were revealed to have been
two of the armors created by Sark
alongside the mark 41 but weren't
deployed until as time with the
guardians of the galaxy as a result
almost nothing about these suits is
known aside from the fact they contain
the standard load out of repulsor
signage concussions and a uni beam with
a mark 45 possessing two shoulder
mounted lasers and the mark 46 using
numerous missile launchers located on
the shoulders arms legs and hands
following this we get into our final
armor as part of this video before
getting into all-new all-different
Ironman in this instance we actually
jump to superior Ironman or the endo sim
armor coming out of the 2014 axis
storyline and the inversion of both hero
and villain personalities at the events
conclusion Tony Stark is shielded
himself from the Rhian version spell of
dr. doom Scarlet Witch red skull and
others allowing for the version of Tony
Stark in the comics to take on a
personality almost identical who is
Marvel Cinematic Universe counterpart to
this end the NSM armor uses a liquid
smart metal and functions as a hybrid
between the extremis armor and the same
organisms as the venom and carnage
symbiotes what this means is that like
the Soviets the Indus MC responds to
Tony's mental commands allowing him to
some of the armor from another location
to his physical body or use the armor as
it means to entrap others or provide a
protective casing
however the suit is effectively linked
to Tony meaning that unlike the
symbionts the suit cannot graft itself
on to another being allowing them to use
its abilities it should also be noted
here that the suit itself does not
possess any form of intelligence and is
simply linked to Tony who is mental
commands the NSM armor also differs from
the symbionts in that because is a smart
metal it's protected against sonic
attacks unlike the no more carnage but
still maintains a series of nanomachines
and like the extremis armor when it
embodies Tony's physical form this suit
essentially becomes another Iron Man
albeit far more advanced than previous
versions in this respect because it was
designed to carry out Tony's view of a
utopia with himself ruling over San
Francisco
the suit was designed to cope with
virtually any and all threats both hero
and villain alike as a result in
addition to the standard load out of
repulsor saunas concussions and a
uni-beam the armor contains thrusters on
the elbows allowing for more impactful
punches as well as the ability to
release tendrils similar to carnage and
that rather than placing sentient beings
under storage control the tendrils allow
for the subjugation and manipulation of
all forms of technology including other
Iron Man suits furthermore the defense
systems of the Indus emceed allow for to
withstand the electrical charge of storm
which uses her control over lightning
incorporates additional mass from its
original compound allowing Tony to
become larger in size and rather than
simply having a face plate that slice
upwards but leaving the face of stark
vulnerable a honeycomb lattice material
called graphene serves to allow Starks
face to be seen while keeping it
protected from small-arms fire
with that being said we're going to
bring this video to an end and that
actually brings us up-to-date with
all-new all-different marvel and so once
we actually get into the first story arc
of Tony Stark we'll focus more on what
the all-new all-different armor is
capable of and how it's actually far
more advanced than any of the suits that
he's ever had so far
with that being said I will catch you
guys letting pace